- [Charlie] You know what,
I was also,
I really believe,
I really actually believe
your take on the
business of music.
The B2C and B2B--
- Correct.
- [Charlie] take on
music is interesting.
Interesting to me because
I think your perspective
couldn't have me look at it
differently and allow me to
activate areas that exist
that we haven't sort of--
- [Gary] And you know
what the best part is?
And this how we're gonna start
jamming right from the get,
I'm so crazy on this.
I'm gonna say everything
diarrhea and throw up.
Like, you know when that happens
weirdly when you're really sick?
And you'll know
what to do with it.
- [Charlie] Right.
- I have no,
I don't give a fuck.
- [Charlie] Right.
- For real.
You know what to do.
But I know intuitively and
I don't know the music business
at all but I know this,
they're famous as fuck
and there's so much
opportunity for disruption
in an interesting way.
Here's why.
The money is not
at the end consumer
in the way that it
always was, we all know that.
Streaming, all this.
Can't make money on the records.
What a duh-duh, but there's
so much money in brand.
So much which is
what I've been spending
the last seven years on and
there's so much money in access.
So much.
And you got to,
and that won't go away
for a very long time and
you have all the permission
to own the fuck out of that.
(hip hop music)